gaana donald rob las elecciones
presidential as Donald Trump's election
as president was being watched very
closely in Latin America Mexico is the
us's biggest trading partner and it was
rattled by the billionaire's
extraordinary wins El Colegio electoral
in Mexico City they were surprised more
than anything else
woke up at 2:00 in the morning realize
they see the result it was like oh we're
doomed
I think it's gonna be a tough time that
doesn't mean that's gonna be a bad time
it depends on how we all work it out as
well Trump he doesn't like Mexican
people for many reasons so with Trump in
the put India as president of USA I
think it's gonna be a many changes even
for Mexican people El Paso is a city
right on the Mexican border across
America exit polls show that nearly a
third of all the tea no Americans
actually voted for Donald Trump when I
was just like standing in the queue
right now to come into a pass oh I was
listening to a lot of people talking
about that so many of them were just
like saying you know I voted for Trump
because Hillary seemed like a liar you
know and at least from has the guts to
speak his mind
so talk of the wall talk of immigration
talk of him deporting people in some
cases not on their mind definitely well
yeah we're talking about US citizen
citizen Mexicans you know they are on
Mexican heritage but they have their
papers assured of this side of the
border those were the people who was
boarding for Trumbo was where the
Mexicans voting for Trump 25,000 people
cross this border into America every
single day but it's also the Gateway for
guns drugs and people trafficking and
Donald Trump put that at center stage of
his campaign more than half of the
us-mexico border is made up of a fence
just like this one and Donald Trump
wants to replace it with a big wall of
course now that he's president he can do
just that
but he runs the risk of not just
dividing
two countries but dividing communities
as well
that's what Valerie
Hadiya thinks she crosses the border
from neighboring Juarez to El Paso to
study everyday my first reaction was
anger why because first I have a lot to
lose first of all I'm a woman I'm latina
and I live in a borderland and if you
have follow Donald Trump you may see
that he's against all that he hasn't
even taken office yet but many are
speculating about whether mr. Trump will
actually follow through on some of his
most high-profile promises the future
relationship between Mexico and its
closest neighbor is about to be put to
the ultimate test
Nick Martin Sky News on the US Mexico
border